thank you very much to come despite the
fire dangers and the wilderness and I'm
very happy to be back in Berkeley in
particular not only because I see old
friends and new friends but also because
dick our the cap our all the beloved
professor is here so Algrim let me tell
you I'm giving this talk but this
project now a twisting some and temporal
order has received a lot of help from a
wonderful team and jinkies a chief
scientist of all around and so at this
point when you you see all kinds of lots
of names of it they are really behind it
so you realize that the project has
evolved but I find out about that to
speak about at a high level in the
original the original vision things are
a little bit an or easier to understand
so I'm going to give you a very high
level description of what a Largo and
works and what the problem is it will
try to solve ok I'm not going to give
you a vague latest and greatest but I
can hint about some new things what we
are doing
I hope all right so by the way everybody
knows what a blockchain is presumably
yes but I'm going to say it anyway so it
is a decentralized database right that
is a you must satisfy three properties
that is readable by anyone anybody can
write an entry in West database and
somehow nobody can alter the database so
visa the data is appears in block think
of what is inside the block some
transactions think of it payments was a
simple kind of a transaction and these
blocks are chained because nobody should
be able to alter the content of a block
nor the order of a block ok but
everybody should be able to to see them
and is not a database that I keep in in
secret and you ask me question and tell
you what the content of a databases
everybody should have a copy of its
database
on your own laptops okay everybody reads
everybody can write and nobody can
change it all right so what is good is
such a structure turns out of it is good
for a lot of things one things these
cryptocurrencies because you start with
a bunch of money that initially you you
declare who was what buy some honey and
then you start making payments to other
people and then more people you keep
tracking these are blocks or about to
owns or how much money and so ever
anytime that you make a payment is clear
of a payment is valid and so and so
forth of it is one typical application
already we are already two thousand and
nine hundred comparators blockchains and
cryptocurrency so you must have some
enthusiasm to to enter into this arena
it's a wonderful application and we are
but another one is in my opinion a more
fundamental to to us as a society is
really the centralization
disintermediation rather I want to say
but we are somehow we can transact
without having a guarantor of a
transaction the transaction beta I we
are going to discuss a little later and
that is actually one application which
is really I think is fundamental you
know then it has been said that does so
many things that even cures of a common
cold
here is a guy very sad he as a cold I
sympathize with him he goes to the
blockchain and as you know everything is
better than the book chain right all
right
so they blockchain promises immense
because who does not like a database
beta is in alterable
who does not like you know transparency
who does not like the ability to
generate trust between people who barely
know each other
the applications are essentially
unlimited however there is a constant
challenge here in this blockchain and
that that is a tension between
aspiration and technology and so somehow
they have been a very big gap between
what block chains are defined as
structurally as
this database which is readable by
everybody heard of all by everybody in
an unalterable somehow all people you
can do and what actually technology
backs up always claims is a little bit
of much tougher
however aiming very high aspirations is
our duty as humans Oh
eventually a waiver we should sustain
our aspiration with some technology
otherwise they will remain a pie in the
sky
excellent looks very good but we cannot
have it and so don't take my word but
there is the famous or trilemma
enunciated by butene way one of the
founders of ethereum is a very famous
blockchain and essentially the trilemma
says beta in a blockchain you cannot
have all these three properties security
decentralization and scalability just
imagine if this were true let me tell
you but there are no good options over
here so just imagine I set up a company
which is a blockchain by design and you
come to me and you say I need the
blockchain that's very good
somebody you know matter lemma so you
want an insecure blockchain you don't
know well maybe not you want a
blockchain which is not scalable well
what do you want to do to to play with
friends and family or you don't want to
ever blockchain which decentralize about
this is decentralized and so essentially
there are no good options right it's
like if I tell you do you prefer that I
shoot you on the left knee or in ba
right knee so given the choice I don't
have to avoid so they try lame a fee
where - it's really not acceptable
should all pack up and go home
but fortunately these faults right so it
is it has been for many many many moms
so true for all thousands over a
blockchain but doesn't mean that the
vSphere properties cannot be achieved at
all at once
[Music]
then scalability so they they complain
that was the way the story goes but it
can be me so I don't know i i'm telling
things but I didn't witness personally
and to say well the work chain is not in
our fastest in fast enough physics what
do you want so so you cannot have all
three so we'd better sacrifice some but
let me tell you what I actually believe
that the usual victim the truth is that
the usual victim is a decentralisation
because well an insecure blockchain you
cannot sell it to anybody right so who
wants it so if you want to ever
something which is not scalable really
essentially you are not in business
because you need to scale otherwise to
to be profitable or so what are you
going to sacrifice is really the
centralization which it should be at the
essence of a blockchain and and so let
me tell you why do we need to sacrifice
because there is a problem here to solve
in the problem what is it in a chain in
a blockchain there are two aspects one
aspect if you're not a category sounds a
tremendously difficult to guarantee they
in Altair ability of a database that is
easy that is done by prehistoric
photography the fine crystal photography
before Shafi and i got into the scene so
the one way ash function right so you
take a block you hash it to one way hash
it and you make this entry part of the
next block and believe it or not I'm not
going to talk about the VESA here today
this guarantees that the chain cannot be
altered not nothing the content of a
blocks not in the holder of the blocks
but you know because people want to
write and they try to push a transaction
to the blockchain somebody must to
append a new block or new transaction to
chain the chain must grow so what is the
problem who chooses the next block
that's the
now when doesn't seem to be a
mathematical problem well it's not
mathematical comment can be solvable if
I say if you don't mind I choose the
block of the next block
right but that is a tremendous power
because remember in a block chain is a
really by ground truth so the
transaction whether happened are the
ones posted in the block because of the
entire world sees what has happened it's
common knowledge right so if I have the
power to choose the next block in a
block chain I have more power when we
quatorze of a quintessential absolute
monarch right are used to head because I
decided bees of a transaction that have
happened in the world and deserve a
transaction I don't want to remember
never happened this is a mitzvah where
power is who chooses the next block and
maybe somehow theoretical computer
science mathematics have to solve this
ball which is not exactly the usual
problem that you you meet on or in math
books so let me tell you why this is a
problem okay let's assume we are at the
beginning of a blockchain where a block
1 block 2 and the question is what is
going to be block free and so let's
assume that you have here these are five
people the block the game was red the
purple in the orange multiplied by a
billion anyway we know planet earth for
humans okay and then these people what
do we do they transact
so if you multiply by billion with an
accurate picture of the possible users
and here is another these people want to
transact mister payments seem very
simple case of a transaction and so
anytime that I want to make a payment
right for me to shot it from my public
key I digitally sign it send the payment
to Shafi I push in Verret work and
disseminate these payments which is
started getting propagated over the
network so what really happens is not
this picture but this all these payments
may go around the other way and they
generate a full of dust and which you
know anybody sees anything anymore let's
have a dust settle because I have a
power of a laptop otherwise is
continuously going and you never know
happens unless they were snapshot so
let's assume what is my current vision
of the green in a year seen payment
number P 1 P 2 and P 99 so in his mind
his block is concealed in the next block
book could be free consists of these
blocks and the hash of a previous block
the block player sees P 1 P 5 P 99 and
so in his in his mind the block is ver 2
plus the ash of the previous block now
notice one thing beta P 1 has been seen
by the green and also by the block and
so as P 99 but P 3 has been seen by the
green but not by the block player in
this case because messages over the
network of a go of the speed of light
food routers and things that's very nice
but they don't propagate eastern
Tennessee so a message when by the flow
to become first to me and then to you or
first to you and then to me so it is my
block in my mind is vests your block is
vests there will be a big overlap but
there is also going to be a delta a
difference between these two sets right
so something that you see and I don't
and vice versa therefore my broken your
block and donnell coincide and so when
the question really is which of these
two block the green or the black or the
orange over thing there are five billion
people five billion opinions about the
next block is which of this block should
we add to the blockchain by the way he
doesn't matter so far so far abroad to
contains the valid transaction if we are
the green block the black block because
we are all good right - pedo splitter
soon we get all transaction button obey
but we have to decide which one okay let
me tell you how this problem has been
approached in the past and here is a way
the first approach was a proof-of-work
which was the invention or mister or
missus of Nakamoto or vena Komodos we
don't know how many
and it was the first idea and it was a
brilliant idea however you know needs
some improvements here is why what is
video Vidya is my following listen I
don't want to say that you should be in
charge of doing the next block or a fun
fun when X block so who is going to do
it we live a computational game there is
a cryptographic querido the first one to
solve a riddle is very right to have
touch he's a rare block to the
blockchain okay ready go people try to
solve a computational riddle by think of
it like plugging random values to a very
strange equations until they the
equation is satisfied you get at zero
right when you when you do it say a here
is my solution to the riddle and here's
my block and but you want also that this
riddle is so hard that at any point in
time no many or many people try to find
very go solve a riddle you have one
solution every 10 minutes why because
you want to prevent that you have two
solutions a few seconds in each other
because if you have two solutions of a
second of each other then the chain
rather than being a chain he has a fork
because you say well it's a possible
continuation is a block with a good
solution to the riddle
let's another block of a good solution
from a legal and which branches of the
Chinese and when this happens eventually
one of the branches of the ice and but
you don't know exactly what were my
Chinese right so that is the problem by
distant shading making the riddle so
hard that you have a solution every pens
ten minutes you make it very improbable
that there is going to be two solutions
a few second of each other but if you
decide that you want to produce blocks
faster every minute rather than a minute
a minute if your riddle is easier
because now it takes a 1 minute then the
probability the two solution of your
second of each other may arise goes as
potentially high up and so then you ever
an exponential growth for Forks and
that's very hard to even to distinguish
in this big
spaghetti mess we're the longest chain
is it's basically R so that is a great
idea which has a democratic ring to it
anybody could do it and which person
actually does it to which user does it
is the first wins of a game of the
computational game but what is the
drawback a is law and B is expensive
because in fact I don't know if you if
you google minor B the way nobody thinks
about mining the very old-fashioned for
the miner you get to know a Bitcoin
miner okay would you find the racks and
racks and racks and racks or specialized
hardware it's the only way in which you
have actually a chance to make money by
mining in Bitcoin very expensive and
when things get very expensive so bad
first of all expensive and slow is a
hard sale expensive and fast I can
understand but expensive a slow is hard
to sell but the independent of this when
something becomes very expensive what
happens that fewer and fewer and fewer
people can afford the expense so what
ever wanted to be a decentralized system
the factor becomes centralized so much
so that the Bitcoin blockchain is
controlled by three mining pools is this
decentralized not according to me
certainly one is even worse but two is
bad and three also okay okay never mind
expensive fast centralized let's move on
delegated proof of stake but is a very
simple idea very low-tech and he says
well look at these 21 people don't they
look honest yes they do and don't you
think like me that we will continue to
be honest in the foreseeable future yes
why don't we put them in charge of
selecting then the next block on behalf
of all of us for the next month or or
something of it earlier okay so is this
decentralized no but it's even worse
than Bitcoin because a Bitcoin somehow
try to be decentralized and somehow as a
side product or expenses and things got
centralized this approaches that's being
centralized from the get-go
okay
next Bond the proof of stake what does
this mean
okay Oh in Boulder proof of stake we are
not like a delegator delegated to phooey
bonded good what does it mean but bonded
we allow not 20 people but 20 200 2000
as many as we want people to put push a
lot of money in the middle of a table
well they can not touch it anymore and
the people who push him a man in the
middle of a table are the ones who
generate the next block on behalf of all
of us and their influence in generating
the block the next block is proportional
to the money but we put in the middle of
a table and if they misbehave their
money gets confiscated Wow let mails it
right well let me ask a different
question perhaps a simple equation how
much of your disposable income can you
afford to put him the middle of a table
hostage my suspicion is going to be very
little so in a system like this you make
it easy for rich thieves with deep
pockets to put a lot of this
proportional amount of money in the
middle of a table for her sole purpose
of controlling the blockchain
and then you say much so what if they
misbehave if the money gets confiscated
well not so fast there is a lot of bad
things that you can do without
triggering any confiscation of your
money so for instance think about the
norm in an auction which do you want to
use a blockchain for doing an auction of
course because you have a transparency
right everybody can see the bids
everybody can see where winner is
it's block chains are great but assume
the blockchain is controlled by three
guys so I can actually tell them if
you're selling your building I put my
bid don't put any bit above
mine the end Oh confiscate shove his
money because I know she didn't put to
my bid chef you can say with total
deniability which bid I didn't see it
right so it's not so easy all this fun
so let me there are all kinds of
approaches but you know there is a
common flow in my opinion so that is a
is a subjective statement here theta is
common to always a other approach that
somehow the whole economy works if and
only if the majority of a small corner
of economy are honest okay who are a
small corner all the members of a small
corner of economy in puffle work the
miners okay I don't know if there are
economists over here but in the global
GDP what fraction of the global GDP is
represented by the miners you need not a
magnifying glass
not a microscope or perhaps an
electronic microscope because it's just
a speck investing so to make sure of it
that you take of a global economy and
you put it in the hands of a few it I
think it's a recipe for disaster
so okay so then so at argon that we
decided to be able to have to start from
scratch because some time is better to
start from scratch even to patch up
things not all the time but sometimes
and so we started from scratch in the
what approach should we use we use a
pure proof of stake not delegated not
bonded pure what does that mean that
means wait the money is never hostage
and where is the man if is not on the
table hostage well is where it should be
in your wallet in your fingertips ready
to be spent or invested in the various
financial opportunities and that the
blockchain offers you wherever best man
is going to be in your hands invested or
anything else
you ask yourself a question is the
majority of the money in honest ends if
yes the system cannot be compromised put
in another way
who can sink a pure proof of stake
system the owners of the majority of
memory that they decided to collude with
each other and shoot themselves in the
foot to destroy the very economy of
which they own the majority of in my
opinion that is a preferable approach
because is less likely less best to
happen okay okay
so that is at eye level conceptual
whatever approaches and very tight ll
never what we are going to do if they'll
go and we how do we choose the next
block believe it or not for somebody who
knows bases not at eye level we agree on
every single block and the agreement is
actually so-called the Byzantine
agreement which is a very strong notion
invented eyepieces szostak and lumpur
and don't confuse it with an adjective
Byzantine agreement because sometimes
when in put an adjective Byzantine
agreement changes meaning completely and
is not as strong as notion as is written
here what is a Byzantine agreement is a
communication protocol the people in
this room start talking to each other
each one of us starts with one value in
our heads we have a majority of honest
people in the room that's the assumption
you can see you with dishonest over
there we have a single value and we talk
talk and talk at the end of our
conversation two properties are
guaranteed the first property is called
agreement all the people who are dear to
via communication protocol to the letter
they have out to put to the same value
when the same volume therein
let's property number one yes but I will
disclose this one later a little bit of
suspense whatever the value is we start
with some values we talk a talk and talk
all the people who honesty follow the
protocol think the same value you know
better
easy you know what this huh white is
easy because here is a polar called a
dozen right away no matter what your
value initially is agree on zero yes
ma'am all they're honest people who
follow the border girl I'm here on 0 but
this is not meaningful and that's why
you need the big consistency property
the consistency property says that just
in case everybody started with the same
value say 27 then not only all the
honest people should agree on this on a
common value but they should agree on
the Larry value of a started with in
other words we should agree on 27 not on
0 or 1 or anything else it's best clear
message of Apollo it's very when you
look at this Oporto you start saying you
know that should be easy to produce a
poor door does these two guarantees my
suggestion is try and then look at after
your solution the day later and at least
for one or two times there is going to
be an error somewhere right okay so if
we visit by something agreement what are
these values these values are what we
said before I have an image in my mind
what the next block was to be you have
another image at the end we want to
agree on a common block on one block
right we want to get on the book so okay
great but if these are three people
design such poor results and ever since
of Inogen original design beware other
problems why don't we plug in from the
literature dig out a Byzantine agreement
protocol plug it in and you agree on the
block we have done we have a new block
chain not so fast
why because Byzantine agreement is very
slow defines law in any practical
application there were 12 participants
in the protocol 12 in a blockchain we
want to end of entire world now there
are billions of people and the second
assumption is that you know that
our set of the buzzient in agreement is
fixed and known in advance
well the vests were to settle it doesn't
apply to a block chain in which
permissionless block chain which users
can come and go and nobody knows that
every single point in time over users
are right so--but there are some
challenges no novelist part over of the
algal and protocol is really give a a
new consensus mechanism that actually is
really super fast and delivers Byzantine
agreement on the nose so we will be able
to agree on on the next block very fast
all right if you'll get this part we are
making Congress we agree on a block and
we agree because there is a known as the
majority majority of the money is in
honest hands we're making progress let
me tell you right away some consequences
of this way of doing things so here is
alga and in action by the way I told you
better agreeing go next block is hard
but there is one block in which we don't
need to agree and what is the genesis
block block number one because that is
part of a very protocol when you define
a block chain you decide what is in
block number one next to block number
one you have a favor
I believe in universal symbol of
lightness and effortlessness right and
so what happens is with as the visa
favor
gently falls to the ground they are gone
blockchain unfolds okay so this is it
wait a second Sylvia watch what happens
to poof for work what happens to Forks
you show us a linear chain well guess
what there are there is no proof of work
in in in Algren why because we don't
have to solve riddles
we had to agree on the block if the
agreement is really fast we are done and
there is no Forks why well because once
we all agree on a single block the
majority of us agrees on a single block
there is not a second block on which the
majority of us agrees in addition
so that's why does not fork and even
these two properties have some
advantages one is weight that you make
easy to people to participate you don't
need to buy expensive hardware to
participate to the Consensus to the
generation or the next block in Algren
that is no proof of work in the forks
means no transaction finality so a very
transaction of finality rather why
because if you get paid in a block do
you ship the goods if you are by
somebody's buying your goods not really
I'd like to ship you the goods but you
know if there is a fork in your payments
and year and then vest payment the
service branch of the blockchain
disappears in my payment and organs paid
so why don't we wait a little bit okay
how much you want to wait well 10 blocks
10 minutes a block my 10 blocks is more
than an hour but they know at some point
in time right he gets you know he gets
much longer than people think
so 12 instead that but you are actually
paid the moment in which a payment made
to you a pier of a blockchain is a big
advantage in finance and all kinds of
other transactions all right so let me
summarize what well gone properties are
again my main assumption is the onus
majority of money and the technical
advantages are the first one the
computation is trivial there are no
riddles so a few additional compares on
a digital signature verification of
seniors are nothing to write home about
the second one is a true
decentralization each token participates
with the same power so if you have a 10
billion tokens out there each token they
are never one token there are no
privileged tokens each token has the
same power as any other talk and when
there is a primer finality of payments
why because we all gone blockchain
doesn't fork actually I lied
Oh a token a token is you know the thing
keep talkin see you have whatever I call
that coins a Bitcoin
okay let's call that token sorry guys
somehow blocked in like language right
so turns out they tell whatever I
described as linear Cheney is a is a
white lie why because the probability of
4k now going to exist but it's very
small
he's a 10 2 by minus 18 okay he's a 10
to the minus 18 looks a very strange a
number of course it's strange because I
made it up but let me tell you why I
chose it because 10 to the power 18 we
have a theoretical physicist Jonathan
with us can confirm is the number of
seconds from the Big Bang until now so
another way to say it is wait if you
produce a block a second which is a very
good clip yes there may be a fork in
Allegan but once in the lifetime of the
universe so I'm afraid to confess that I
don't think I have any hope to see a
fork and I I wish you will but you know
is somewhat improbable okay okay so then
scalability you can generate blocks as
fast you can be propagated provided mr.
bison Tina give me this really fast in
security against a but the diversity how
bad very bad
so in other words this at the verse a so
I'll go and is secure even reason
adversary who was you can immediately go
up to lots of players and they can
coordinated them in addition to it and
or and not only can attack the protocol
but also the communication network on
which the protocol is run and by the way
I believe it is very good to be very
prudent in blockchain because if you
ever really a blockchain should be able
to that work should be able to secure
the trillions of dollars in assets and
the thieves are like mushrooms after
moraine which bring up a there is a
trillion dollars opportunity you'll be
surprised how many cut off attacks to an
802 the protocol of a can guys so we
must be prepared okay so now I want to
give a little bit over-over taste about
really
how does a peasant in a game and guns
and gets into the picture what do we do
how does our go and work algún works in
two magic phases where magic is actually
replaced by mathematics but as everybody
knows magic is a bit easier to
comprehend the mathematics so let's
stick to magic today so two phases what
happens in phase one the proposal phase
by magic our token out of all the coins
in circulation is selected this token
must belong to somebody
there's somebody proposes a block end of
phase one wasn't this easy
good phase two by magic a thousand
tokens are randomly select among all the
tokens and circulations they must belong
to somebody
and this somebody I have the player or a
Byzantine agreement to agree on the blob
proposed by my first person okay
why do we need a second phase because in
any society and a blockchain is no
exception there is going to be a
percentage of bad actors
caimans let's say how many one percent
maybe two percent if you live in a very
dangerous society ten percent I want to
learn myself 20 percent okay but at some
point in time in no society there is a
majority of criminal because by
definition a society is something the
majority whose member follow some rules
okay whatever the society is about so
let's assume we live in a very dangerous
society ten percent of us are criminal
you should not leave the house without a
rifle or hand grenade or things like
this okay body armor bodyguards and all
right and if ten percent of us are
criminal you know select the token or
random 10% of a time belongs to a
criminal in Westham one can do it cannot
steal your man
but he can tell you the block is X me
the blocks is why shove the block is D
thereby creating discord about in we
don't ever change anymore we ever
something totally undefined so that's
why in the second phase where there is
ves agreement because just in case this
guy says the different things to
different people you want to collapse
them into a single block but I remember
with the fail second phase works if the
majority of the members are honest now
it to do a little bit of envelope
computation right to say if 90% of the
people are honest and you take a
thousand of them are random what are the
chances did you get the Fossum people
are random with dishonest majority there
is more you get back into my sir that's
a very minuscule quantity right that's
video so well you don't even need to
decide because it's actually in
essential so they remember vet you know
you may end up agreeing on the same
block I'm assuming I'm bad I tell you
block is X Ginga blocks is why Jonathan
the blocks is it Z etc at the end of a
conversation because you don't know if I
am doing this or not only you know that
you have a starting value of x at the
end with you talk talk talk and we are
given the same thing it could be the
same X so for your point of view say Oh
Sylvia was honest about from gingka
point of view say because I told her he
told me why I been away we are agreeing
at the end of X none of allies she will
agree if she's honest like you on on X
ok but it's not necessary to know to
decide if it was honest or not the
important thing for us is to have a new
block with the certainty but everybody
else who is honest sees the same block
ok let's let's let's the idea all right
so you see that phase 2 is important
because of X is where with high
probability you know that really is
going to be high majority and because
you are randomly selecting with tokens
or think about randomly selecting people
which is a bit easier to think about let
me do a sanity check
say it's okay see November I understood
that the way you're describing Algren is
bit what counts what makes the system
work is vetting you randomly selected
people Soviet you know if there is a
known as majority about a committee with
a I'm a known as the majority but who
selects a miss committee members if I
may ask well just assume for a second I
said if you don't mind I do when he says
you're centralized blah blah blah it's
on so forth so in our grand there is a
little bit of kind of an alert or an
orthodox idea to say these committee
members randomly select themselves gee
this sounds a bad idea actually in fact
assigns sounds a terrible idea even more
when is one of the worst ideas or I
don't say because if you put in charge a
committee to get things work and you
allow this committee member to be selves
randomly selected I randomly selected
myself for this committee thank you very
much in for the next block I am also
randomly selected myself though I got
selected myself right and so on so forth
because we do want to have as much
control as possible but not so fast
because what does it mean that you
select yourself fit as soon as you see
the previous block appear you ask
yourself am i a member of the committee
to approve the next block and to solve
this questions you run in the privacy of
your home computer your own individual
lottery is a micro lottery dedicated to
you only to you think of it like a slot
machine whose lever you can pull down
only once you pull down the lever and if
you win you get a winning ticket namely
a mathematical proof is it to verify
that you are one the Lord again you're a
member of this committee okay and so and
if you win you propagate here is my
winning ticket to listen to my opinion
and here is my opinion about the block
roughly bets let's barrier if you don't
win you're welcome to say anything good
whatever you want but what the win
ticket Europeana is disregarded okay
wait for your turn when you are really a
member of the next committee okay let's
bet failure okay so it's basically
enough so by the way they vest lottery
is a cryptographically fair lottery
what does this mean that not even a
nation state with huge computational
resources could improve even minimally
the chance of winning a lottery or
become you becoming a member of the
committee okay so let me actually argue
that this is really decentralized why is
this decentralized because I'm not
saying that a thousand people select the
blocks next block for the vest month or
for rent next week or for the next day
or for an hour but I gather one block a
thousand people committee next block a
different 1000 people random selected
committee right but more decentralized
and basic cannot be and is really
decentralized up to the token level
because you select the fossum tokens and
the committee members are the owners of
these tokens if two of your tokens are
selected you have two votes in the
committee okay that's really okay
decentralized check how about it being
scalable well how long does it take you
or me or anybody else to operate valori
a microsecond oh this is more and if you
win what are you to do well you
propagate to your winning ticket and
your opinion about the block up or down
that's the scale are you kidding of
course are fastened short messages mm
because you say two things right but
better works with scales and by the way
there are billions of people or
trillions of people we'd get to the
Martians in our book chain too well you
know everybody's welcome
you still need a thousand people
committee who no matter how many users
they are right so that's really scales
so okay now let me argue that this
vessel secure assume I am this a big
scary guy that was telling you but I
gave the magical power to corrupt
instant
any 1,000 users I want in the world whom
I don't want to corrupt the committee
members so they type control over books
but I have a problem I don't know if the
committee members are because who I who
is in the committee the winners of this
lottery that you run inside your home
computer so I have no idea if you want
the Lord of Sheba wounds the lottery of
vacillating Shanghai bunds the lottery
of his guy in Paris I don't know
however as soon as you open your mouth
and say here's my winning ticket and
member on the committee and here is my
opener but the block now I know who is
one for some people out because they
spontaneously disclose themselves I can
convert them right away however whatever
they had to say they already said it and
their messages are virally propagated of
the network and even though I'm very
powerful I do not have the power to put
back into the bottle messages that are
virally propagated over of a network no
more than the US government has the
power to put back in the bottle and
message virally propagated by WikiLeaks
so my system is secure because
beforehand I don't know whom I should
corrupt an ex post is too late to go
after and if you look at this and you
hide a bunch of every type of her I
heard a reasoning that essentially why
betray leymah does not hold right
because but yet to do something a little
bit enough unorthodox in order to bypass
a visa mr. Lima okay you know what I've
been talking here for 45 minutes is time
to come to an old and so far what I've
done I described to you the core
technology valgrind which consists of
this cryptographic sortition service
people self-select themselves as the
best Byzantine agreements is SuperDuper
fast we didn't discuss where but you
believe me why I don't know and the
other one is better at least to give an
idea why doesn't fork right because we
actually argue unavailable so that's the
core technology
check what is next then actually next is
really next because it's going to come
next month is the layer one technology
and let me tell you what does it mean
that means the retinal so far less
technology okay two blocks and you
handle transaction payments but now you
want to do something a little bit more
sophisticated you want to generate
assets say I want to generate my own
tokens in argon can i yes that's what it
means anybody can use either a home
tokens at a layer one what does it mean
a layer one at the consents of survival
without getting too smart contrast if
you know both oh if you know what that
means and we are going to have all kinds
of actually smart contract but very very
simple that we can do in layer 1 and by
the way these layer 1 algo and the layer
1 smart contracts are sufficient to
handle most of the needs for which
people need as much contrast who senses
well I do okay
ok so let me focus on this because there
is not enough time to describe and on
how to us you assets of they are gonna
block chain so let's look at this layer
ones math contracts in there are two
types atomic transfer until script will
figure out good names okay so now good
enough for today
atomic transaction is I think is a good
name so whatever it is a grouped
transaction for simultaneous execution
and what are teal escapes visa custom
gradable layer one contracts using a
very simple language but never mind
we have a time only for one what is very
simple to describe atomic transfers okay
atomic transfer atomic swap is even
simple when atomic transfer because swap
involves only two people okay and in
fact here the two people user one as an
asset X that user two ones and user 2 as
an asset Y that user
we want to exchange shot and I our us
well Nadia Asuma they are digital in the
blockchain so how do we do in in the
quote real world how I've been doing
this for thousands and thousands of
years by having a trust and mediator
call it a bank call it an escrow agent
the colleton or whatever so we asked
[ __ ] whom we both trust I give him my
asset to Jing Chava gives him an asset
to Jing Jing consulate to us and thank
you very much now and they all right but
don't worry because I'm a trusted here
is I give you back at the assets are
either way right okay why not well first
of all because it's loss of a
transaction second of all because Jing
says you mind you know here is my bill
for services rendered she wants to be
paid can you believe it
well let's however world work that's why
Bank makes money right solve it solve a
mirror turns out that six percent of the
global GDP is lost in financial friction
that's a lot ago and I don't see at the
particular in in already evolved the
economies where where'd you find this go
for GDP well if you get a little
financial kitchen you have a sixty
percent at your disposal to invest in
health care or whatever you want six
percent secrecy is the sum McKinsey
northern things are analysts point I
forgot it's all yet to document to miss
things some some better thinking when I
figure out what the last number is okay
we don't want this they are too
expensive and by the way there are also
centralized because right with mediators
and I want to do they want to exchange
assets to buy buy buy helped by hope by
another mediator when the mediator
if you don't does not give you over us
and you're going to super hell out of
him or her therefore he has to be bigger
than you are
so that you have assets against which
you can recover your losses okay
so then very for this media that we gets
a bigger and bigger and bigger and as
you know there are essentially six banks
in the world of the chain which are ever
known as super banks and so on so forth
that's not a way to go in my opinion at
least
so forget that how about smart contracts
well smart contracts we don't have a
time to describe but the way a wonderful
idea of a blockchains but the wave the
following problem they are expensive
they are slow and they are actually hard
to design properly so no day passes by
but somebody loses a million dollar or
two to a model in design smart country
so when you take your asset and you give
it to the smart contract you start
playing with you know this must be
really works because they never see in
this car you see the asses back ok so
thanks about no thanks even if the
worker very very slow in things
how about hash time looks so much people
are suspicious and won't avoid this math
contract that they invented this other
contraption but is very easy to explain
at least visually but never mind them
whatever means the technical means the
befalling I go first why I go first
because they atomic swap it ain't atomic
okay so he's a multi-step swap atomic in
English okay in name only
so I go first and I put on the
blockchain
but digitally sign I transfer my asset
to Shafi temporarily
what does listen me but I give chef Ian
our to post on the blockchain where she
gives him my asset and if she does solve
a transaction is completely honest but
if I posted in tick tick tick tock tick
tock she doesn't do it I guess the very
nervous all of a sudden I post another
transaction and abort transaction say
let's stop this way this after it was
only temporary shellfish now goes back
home okay how about that what's wrong
with that
well first of all it takes an hour we
want to do it in seconds okay let's see
some value there but second of all Shafi
must be able to post a board if I don't
give it a selfish guy thank you Shafi
for your house so thank you very much
now my money is coming but
so can she can prevent me from posting
and a bow transaction how by bombarding
me of nonsense messages so-called denial
of service attack from all kinds of
service so when I'm inundated my
communication lines of this junker
messages
I cannot receive any more messages nor
can I post any other message so an hour
in the case of a house is not good
enough
in fact people in the literature
recommend a day some people recommended
two days and guess what there are people
recommend the three days and if you want
to be mathematical about it it depends
on what the value of the asset is so you
want to continue to have the rules so
that they solve it the denial of service
attack becomes so expensive that at some
point you must stop it and let me post
my bot transaction and therefore
everything is extremely slow so thanks
but no thanks what do we do instead we
do it by a single transaction I decide
not 12 slides because I got lazy so I'll
do it by hands okay it's conceptually
what I want to say is the following
assume that where are the blocks are now
producer 1 2 3 400 now I'm going to sign
by following I seal your transfer my
million-dollar to Shafi
if vestige of mine n Shafi transferring
to me a house together appear in block
101 ok ok when I propagate to the
network this my signature do I worry if
Shafi is reciprocating and propagating a
wrong thing no why because a few seconds
later I look in the sky and rock 101 has
appeared case 1 my signature and Shafi
signatures above there great
Shia's my million-dollar have a house if
my signature is there but not sure fees
the million dollars are not hands at all
because the rules were stated in this
way right invite servers so in other
words
vetti's assumed that somebody bombard me
under the Nidal service attack I cannot
post my signature so what
Shafi doesn't lose anything and I don't
lose anything each one of us keeps her
assets if instead we manage to post this
conceptually single transaction then we
are asked of this transfer okay
so what are they advantages within a
single transaction we have x and y being
even best happens when we keep our
assets the advantage of a single
transaction is of course nobody can
cheat because I can cheat if I go first
than somebody has to go second when I go
further right but if it is a single
transaction in this transaction in the
blockchain we have done and otherwise
enough and then happens a layer 1 which
means it takes 4.5 seconds as much you
get in the block and it's done at the
same security level then then the
consensus which is various security
level and then by the way there are no
errors possible because you don't have
to because it's done at a layer 1 and I
my opinion that is what the trading
ought to be with disintermediated that
is a big advantage of a blockchain if
you think about it this blockchain but
it looks a static object a bunch of
blocks boring boring a second block
further ok nobody can change it but look
at the power the fact if I have a
guarantee based on the majority of
honest Evolver money that blocks appear
with a certain rhythm right
I can talk about I do this if there's
only strophe appears in the same block
it gives me a language to express all
this disintermediation transaction and
that's where my opinion of the real
power of a blockchain is because you are
making your head capable of generating
trust even in assuming that chef and I
never met before we we really can
transact with the real trust as if we
were between friends right lets's Varia
all right and by the way not to make
sure that you know that is only atomic
swaps
you can actually have for instance a
very often in a in a supply chain you
want to say I want the best payment and
base payment and best payment invest
Cohen's invicible conda's in un in euros
and dollars because when you transport
what's an example everybody puts
anything about blockchains coffee
somebody must be paid because grew the
coffee beans somebody must be paid
because brings the coffee beans from the
undies to the plane somebody must be
plain because it puts them on a train
somebody was in Bahia boots on our ship
and the ship goes to Singapore whatever
your everybody must be paid you know
right now with our financial Network
along mistakes three months because all
these Ledger's must be in agreement
instead if you do it this way one two
three done four point five seconds your
exchange again
Avery payment is individually sent I
don't know if everybody else is doing
the same thing or not but I'm sure but I
paid nobody unless I get paid to
different multiple players and the
advantage are the same single
transaction single transaction means no
cheating layer one means fast and no
error or possible no smart contracts in
a little bit of what do we we our
strategy is to do at the layer one in
this similar fashion as much as possible
and all kinds of smart contract
expressed in a very simple language
which consists of a straight line
program of 30 operations like add
compare hash verify digital signature
right these are for over 30 things out
you can do a lot of things you can do
not only let me swap but post and sale I
can post say my house for sale and I go
for vacation at the end I come and see
even somebody as bottom a price I
declared or not only Elsa still is mine
but you can do all kinds of a very rich
things and by the way all these things
are really important for having friction
of violence and because we have no more
time for other things let me bypass
everything and look and we just tell you
a little bit of time they Algar and the
thanks to the effort of a team
got live in generating blocks after
blocks of uranium vulvodynia blocks ever
since last June this November
we are going to have all these atomic
swaps layer ones math courses etc and
what is next
it comes all kinds of things which comes
to the next year code chains virtual
chains whatever that means we have no
time for bed and by the way we have
plans to keep on going ok
stay tuned for whatever else is coming
burger burger chain so let me conclude I
was saying aspiration and technology
what is my take my take is the
technology is quintessential human
always notion that technology is like I
mean humans create their own tools and
technologists do with square cube behind
is equation of the gaze so I and I
believe that the technology is here to
serve humans and no actually I go a step
further and I believe that only true
technology we let us be who we really
want to be thank you time like this
thing what's a vault hmm vault and ok
volt okay both these under smart chain
technology ok so once you solve a
problem it's a blockchain as the vest
beauty but is like a vase a Hydra with
many heads you squash the head then
another head comes up before the
bottleneck was computation to solve a
riddle like men okay you solve it now
computation is essentially to create
them is a very fast Byzantine agreement
and bla bla bla bla you have done it
now what happens you are you can you're
a victim of your own success
you started generating blocks ever if
you
seconds you know after a year or two you
have a terabyte of data and somebody
says when water becomes hard is storage
or actually even handling given to
somebody else's data so he managed to
say oh ho gee I'm now convinced of Al
Gore and the three years ago
I could have a started but I know can I
join of course you can join everybody's
welcome in are gone so what are you to
do I want to participate to the
generation of a block of course it
should that's why we will lower the
level of participation computational
level of participation your laptop can
explain t2 computed okay what do I need
Oh
download the best egg a bite and you're
ready to go so downloading a terabyte
isn't easy right so yeah it takes you
three months and after three months it
to wait a little bit more because in
these three months you have the few more
blocks to my chain so that becomes now
the next bottleneck and so you're a
victim of your own success so what the
vault does essentially it allows to
onboard new users who can participate to
a consensus protocol to the generation
of a block absolutely equal an equal
playing field my English when I don't
sleep he gets a I go back to Italia no
worse it's a baby language so it's a
level please with the people who have
been there from the very beginning so
what happens you join will give you a a
compact piece of information that you
can verify the correctness because if I
give it to you or a friend give it to
you you don't trust anybody you can
verify that this piece of information is
correct and with this piece of in
connection information you can somehow
globe a chain forward keeping the speech
piece of information compact in other
words after three years is not better
you need you have actually to store a
terabyte either you modify this compact
piece of information all along and you
can generate new blocks like me I was an
alga and on day one from the very
beginning not DIF G got to be a
difference yes the only difference is
that the people who were there from the
very beginning and are storing all this
terabyte they are the only one who can
answer I gave all questions such as what
was the best third transaction in block
number two or three years ago well if
you're not there in your compact piece
of information when you get on board and
you cannot figure this out but the
people who have it they also we give
them a technology given it you have it
you can convince somebody by giving
again a compact piece of information who
proves they that the piece that you
wanted to retrieve the from from from
archive is really correct roughly Metis
Vidya Sylvia you had this example
towards the end of your talk about Shafi
selling you the house for a million
dollars so what prevents shopping from
selling a house to two different people
okay vetti's that is very correct so
because because I was a lipstick in my
description and so remember what I was
saying in this conditional language I'm
going to say I seal yourself with stuff
I'm going to say to Shafi and then an e
phenyl if chef is does this and so now
remember but what a layer one you had to
instruct all the verifiers but there is
a new sheriff in town a new transaction
in town is not only a payment but
anytime beta I I define my assets that
are given to Shafi in the same block it
cannot be that I give the same asset to
somebody else so right so a block that
contains a my giving us a to shop in a
given asset to you is invalid okay but I
remember once a waiver the transfer is
done and one of a good thing that we
have in Al Gore and in particular
amendment maybe others ever to but set
there is a good thing is that you keep
track not only of the amount of money
that a public hears but also the assets
that each public hears so once I if I
had Shafi at the house I have a million
dollar if sheffy now wants to a few
blocks later sell their own house
I know that if I are going to believe it
because this house is under Silvia ski
now belongs to see me alright let's
that's enough for the video yeah a
question here I take it change become
enormous Li long is the question of
efficient search something of practical
question that is uh correct
so if you if you want to search for a
transaction of it you don't know where
it is it becomes a it becomes very hard
so if if somebody wants to answer a
camel question is prepared in a in a
particular database area of particular
data structure to to retrieve it so but
if I'm not one of these people and I
arrived X Noble in a look of a stuff I
don't know what it is in fact actually
you asked a very good question because
we have a different technology to handle
this which is somehow we call it a self
verifiable transaction at least whenever
anything will relates to you you have
the ability by looking at the chain but
not storing it to prove at anybody
anybody else whenever you want in a very
compact way anything you want
you own assets or money houses horses
whatever sailboats so of course what is
in your interest to keep this
information around because you want to
to exchange of somebody else then it
becomes very easy to say do you want to
buy my house and by the way here is a
proof that never mind them at that
blockchain has been operating for ten
years this houses is mine because
otherwise you're right because somebody
had to say oh thank you yes I would be
interested in Versailles also looks very
good let me check if you really own it
then I have to go from the beginning of
a blockchain and comb every single block
because the all the house comes in the
blockchain of this block are not here
number three that's good
a few years later all that are now as my
house that is very good and then a
waiver and let me continue checking
because I want to check that Donna has
not salted and swear
so it is a hybrid is if you want to
search it you to get your own data
structure but at least of my owners of
assets we give them our ready-made way
to prove ownership even if it's highly
unlikely do you have a strategy for
pruning a fork yes
but believe it or not we're not putting
in the in the code right now so it
sounds like one's power to influence the
consensus in this system is proportional
to the tokens you have or like that's
how it's assigned whereas in
proof-of-work systems it's obviously by
power to hash whatever function they've
defined is the hash function is there
like do you believe there's a reason
that since you claim this is more
decentralized why or like how the system
will prevent ownership of these tokens
from somehow becoming centralized or at
least like more centralized than you
would want it to be well so let's
remember one thing so first of all the
system is decentralized and we sense of
it every token as the same power so if I
don't have any token why should I have
any power in a blockchain nobody told it
but the same token if you own 10 times
as many tokens as I have you have a
little bit more interest but to make
sure that the best system works
correctly so you are going to have a 10
times more probability to participate in
the consensus of it I have right but I
think that it's only right that is so by
the way should be the varies a
difference between owning and even
central power in the same way best
forming sense let's assume that I own
and 90 percent of a tolerance ok and the
venn at that point you can be guaranteed
that I'm going to be honest because if I
started being dishonest right and I want
to buy I don't know a sofa Doug as a
furniture store say oh I like my sofa so
do you mind if I pay you in our ground
as well I'm sorry I think
a lot of flow doesn't mean happening I
don't want to so I devalue my own money
so remember the mining power is a bit
different because it's a little bit
different because the Niners have all
the power and no money relatively
speaking right so very easy all economy
they own a very little piece of it is a
different story
if if I owned a ninety percent of an
economy let me show written all the last
thing I want to do by the way by doing
this I can vote blocks proposed blocks
more often but I can never suck your
money into me because this money
transfer is operates only via a digital
signature of yours that I cannot fake
thank you Mike
yes thank you couple questions so first
of all if it's really really successful
and you have all this data you've got a
store you can't have it stored in any
one particular location to kind of need
a distributed storage solution correct
so have you thought about that
no it's one step at a time another I do
a hand or somewhere else
I'll tell you it'll be a nice format to
solve it yes sure all right so if you
managers are all wants to take this then
you must find a different way to
represent all this stuff or you start
saying me you know what a couple
questions that go back 3,000 years we no
longer care about well that was my
second question is there a way to kind
of get rid of stuff because at some
point just gonna have too much stuff and
someone's gonna be irrelevant so you
want to get rid of it somehow well as I
said but in some sense if the stuff is
always there but they whatever you have
a super structure which is viscom packed
with information but is the one that you
care to go forward right so at any point
in time it is not it is very clear who
owns what whoever money or asset and out
to grow the chain and then the rest is
for historians may be interested in it
and then after 3,000 years who bought a
chair from whom he becomes a lesser
hello thanks
yes all these are good ideas but but we
had to figure out oh for what reasons if
you want to summarize by chain from the
porpoise ongoing the chain forward then
we don't need to summarize it or in some
sense this compact piece of information
you can call it a summarization of a
chain so I call it a compact piece of
information that allows you to grow by
chain forward but you can actually do it
in your language as a summarization
yes but or you can actually do you can
do all kinds of things and say I want to
periodically every hundred years I want
to have at least a snapshot of who owns
what to help a story and so later on
sure but you can do it too
and by the way and you don't need the
somehow using this voltage you can
actually do this quite efficiently
because once you start storing a piece
of a chain and then nothing and then
another piece yet to be careful because
you know how do you know where this
piece is correct so yeah but what do we
do is that we have a we have a proof for
correctness of every single piece and
miss before characters involved is
anchored to guess what they Genesis
block which is the only block on which a
very certainty I think it was in 87 you
had written with your collaborators that
are all games with honest majority can
be efficiently played that assumes a
static corruption model for these no it
was dynamic but they assumed something
rich in ohm
I never realized before it was a
limitation that the number of players
was known in advance so this is a
multi-party computation 1987 yes at 88
we fought a cryptography with Sharpie 87
a million companies shopping company
epigraphy very where games in which you
say the players are ABCD
yet to know vet and so these are a
different story because
you don't even know what the players are
and by the way another thing of it is a
little beaten or bizarre and this never
happened to me in the service protocol
wasn't in protocol that I'm hiding as
much as I can because it's hard to
explain in an hour as a one property but
I never dreamed of which is a player of
a possibility let me tell you what to
play or helpless abilities means of the
following that that the protocol works
even if say for some people get up and
speak okay and then a totally different
one for some people get up and speak and
then a totally different one for some
people get up and speak ok with no
connection with each other not you you
don't exchange variables you don't share
state in a stateless manner ok so ok
what kind of what is a protocol is an
intelligent conversation
what kind of intelligent conversation
can you possibly have when the people
get up and say something and then some
unrelated people say something else with
no connection not having shared every it
seems impossible well there are a few
things that you can do that for instance
if a thousand people get up and each one
of them shouts enough a random number
between one and a thousand and then the
next time for some people get up and
shut some number within one and a
thousand and so on so forth it is the
same as if the same set of 1,000 people
each time shots a random number between
one and a thousand but what are we doing
nothing
we're charting number random numbers so
this stuff we can be done in a player
replaceable way or can be done by the
same people strange thing is wait there
are actually a class of pourable that
actually are player pleasurable and
guess what is player replaceable is
bagent in agreement
and that to me was the source of pricing
retinol I never in 40 years of work with
Shafi and ever thought about even
defining this I miss type of thing no
player replace ability which means of it
and all you don't need the same players
they so the protocol is played by some
players and then by some other player
totally unrelated and we thought any
priority mentor without the sharing
information the one thing that I can do
I can describe is of a the following
first of all think about our war movie
hopefully the movie rather than reality
even boy has been a reality tonight so
what you want to bring the flag you know
from your side to enemy side if you do
you in that's the game ok and then what
happens is if you see in the movie they
movies because if they do a same scene
over and over again you start carrying
the flag then where it carries a flag
right gets killed and when it's about to
kill somebody else catch them from I can
continues do you care who actually
carries a flag at the end no you only
carry the flag is carried over
everything so in some sense this happens
also in this type of class of portables
there are strangely enough a few things
that you can do in a player in a
political way so the world's financial
system as of say 2000 which is this sort
of ad hoc mixture of cash and bank
accounts had a couple of features right
one is that small ish transactions can
be conducted with a degree of privacy
and anonymity that's pretty good
and another is that large transactions
and even medium-sized ones governments
can step in and say freeze assets
whether it's because somebody hasn't
been paying their child support or
because somebody's a terrorist these are
both sort of broadly desirable features
to have and I'm wondering in what way
they can be realized sort of in this
schema okay so first of all when you say
there are desirable features like in
anything else in life they are desirable
in one scenario and non desirable
another scenario because if
in a dictatorship and all of a sudden
the dictator doesn't like me anymore
because I looked at him or her sideways
I am lucky if I run with my life in a
pajama and my assets are frozen right so
if in a blockchain
bun well you know when you want to run
or anyone to run and you don't have time
to pack things right so it's all and it
says I leave behind the house I leave it
behind my money my bank account is
frozen right I mean I mean we are very
fortunate in our country to think that
the ability of freezing somebody's
assets is a good thing because helps law
enforcement and things and you know in
some other countries we are very very
lucky I guess okay second of all I want
to say so certainly you cannot freeze
assets you can decide to run Algar and
on a country level meaning that you
decide your monetary policy going to
decide to inflate or deflate or whatever
you want to do but you enable your
countrymen to transact without the
mediators so you say the 60% of your own
GDP this is good but freezing my assets
you cannot do well again it is a problem
it's not or not so I don't say okay so
I'm saying if we do live in a in a
superstructure but there is a course and
things if I don't play alimony or child
support when they get me in some other
way but the notion of it the way to get
me by freezing the assets that is a
historical fact that actually happens
because of the way money is angle right
now but it's not to be something
sacrosanct it has to be written anywhere
so I'm by the way
for more enforcement right by all means
but what I'm saying
why should arrive via money is so law
enforcement it's okay we need the law
enforcement but not necessarily met them
a way to express itself has to be via
facing symbology as assets okay
promising anonymity and first of all
other photographers we love privacy
right
and here I'm describing the system with
a vanilla privacy over the pseudo
anonymity over all the key so I just I
have a one key Robin keeping all my
money monkey I create some new gear
transfer some other money nobody knows
about these other ten keys are mine and
maybe I want to be a bit more power so
Betsy's a vanilla thing if you want to
want to do at the privacy you can but
but you need that totally different type
of technology so here at Berkeley is
Alessandra here Oh calling some is the
co-founder on Zika which is really a lot
of beautiful mathematics great goes into
making sure with the blockchain a really
private not pseudo private but really
bad in the sales you know right now I am
unsure about doing it because by the way
I care about law enforcement so you
don't want to be they keep the system or
money launderers even right so so and
and until we figure it out I'll be very
hesitant so I'm sure but it should
happen I can put all the price in the
world and then they're ready to give a
master key to the government and
necessary but then you know is a bit
more complicated I feel a bit you know I
want to get there later when I am
satisfied with a solution so my question
is more on the Byzantine agreement so
according to these slides I might be
wrong you start off with only Regenesis
block one block so and the addition of
next block actually depends on the
Byzantine agreement so the probability
of having a 51% attack in that case is
more right how do you mitigate that what
if my next block it keeps on adding
malicious nodes or blocks how do you
mitigate that Oh remember you don't add
nodes so so there are keys nodes are for
transmission over and geographically
location saying versus a it's not not
ism there are keys who owns money right
okay and so and then what happens is
beta you will use sample for some tokens
again okay
and the owners of this wasn't tokens are
the committee okay so so when yet to
play a little bit with the math so if
you assume of it you have a 90% honest
thing you want to make sure that you
select a font organs or if it's not the
thousand it's two thousand so make sure
that you have a two-thirds honest the
majority in your thousand or two
thousand that is video so then when you
must make sure but for every single
block you must sure but this probability
is very very low I said the 10 to the
minus 18 so if you keep on insisting
eventually you'll find a committee with
a dishonest majority or whether
majorities more than it should be who
are the participants when you have just
one block on lady Genesis block and you
are agreeing on something so there is
only one participant right now so how do
you manage okay so but remember beta V
assumption so no theorem follows without
the assumption we need assumptions
axioms if you want n rules of inference
so the axiom here is that at any point
in time the majority of the money is in
honest hands if at the Genesis block I
only have the money by assumption I most
okay all right so by the way then I can
actually explain notes in English is in
my interest as I was saying before to be
honest because if I'm the so honest I
did
very money with I actually sir excellent
but what I'm saying by mathematically
you know honest majority means if there
are a million people in each one as my
same amount of money then if he is
ninety percent of his people are nine
hundred thousand of these people it's a
million nine hundred thousand are honest
if if there is a twelve people and one
of the disproportion amount of money
maybe the first two are honest that
would satisfy all these other five or
whatever so you mentioned how every
token has an equal hey how are you right
so you mentioned how uh you know you
think it's a essential part of proof of
stake that every token has an equal vote
but you also want to issue assets right
that will represent different things so
I guess how do you think about proof of
stake security when there's all these
different assets floating around on the
same chain that might have different
values and might represent different
things very acute observation
I haven't thought about it yet I think
that it's going to be maybe a necessary
step but maybe not but somehow the old
world system is is hinged on the fact
that um by talking about cells and
perhaps Anor you may want to change the
moral to say well now assets have a
reason to be voted to and and that maybe
is a different model and I I don't know
how to orchestrated this but you're
right in principle we want to say I want
to also miss our we suffer I want to
count assets why is it harder because
it's harder to because now you have a
assessing the value of these assets and
I can think of a bunch of ways to do so
and but right now or do I want to stick
my neck to say oh we're so good this way
or assesses I'm saying you know one day
I think I'm a model for and invest
another day the model switches
and I are really not sure what the right
model is but it's a very good point and
I was wondering what happens to tokens
that don't participate in the protocol
like if my laptop is like something and
yes you could do it so the way we we do
practically in algorithm is better we
give you a chance when to register
yourself as a participating or not
participating if you are not
participating meaning no disregard from
the counter of the total stake my coins
because I only want to transact but a
normal to participate to the consensus
and then that's why I was wondering for
those who perceive participate are the
messages broadcast to the whole network
every single ok so then there is in the
original design so we we had the vests
appear to be broadcasting right and then
until we figure out a way to do al grant
in a way that is partition resilient ok
before ago which is another property
that I didn't even discuss and
essentially at eye level so if you want
I can dive into this a bit more but like
it somebody else want to have another
question or we can do it offline
what does partition resilient means a
better or is secure against network
attacks ok so if it is secure against
the network attacks by the way bitcoin
is not secure against network attacks
which for some reason not everybody
mentions in a very single time but it
should be major because right people
think of it my miners there is honest
majority and all the mining power then
bitcoin is secure
but it's not normal to even all miners
can be all honest and bitcoin is not
secure why because let's assume of it
the miners are equally distributed on
the planet and somehow I disconnect
South America one of the five populated
continents
why I use five because I get he's a
better way 506 forget them tactic okay I
disconnected so okay so when when what
happens beta somehow a chain in South
America continues
but we've speed the one five high in
Bitcoin and the other chain in the rest
of the world continuous period of four
four out of five right so we speed the
forum with speed one so if I
disconnected for a while I create a fork
I can double spend in South America and
then when law and order is restored to
the cables whatever happened to my
network about her elders have been
reconfigured correctly then everybody
sees in beta the chain was on way on the
longer side then even the self America
migrated to mine over that so what does
it mean if somebody attacks my network
all the Niners are honest all the self
American miners were doing a fine job
there - in the rest of the world are all
honest but by simply disconnecting my
network I can double spend in South
America okay so what is something that
the network is an attacker my network is
lethal to Bitcoin and I claim is not
lethal amalgam and I'm going to give you
a very vague proof you need a certain
threshold say of seven hundred of a
thousand signature to mint a block in
our gun right so people agree I ought to
put right this block is signed by me and
seven hundred people so that's it
although for some people committee then
if you attack the nectar so to speak at
least this particular attack fails
because even in no part of the world
after the nectar is partition you have
seven hundred signatures of the same
block or you have it to know in very her
in for four continents and not in South
America so what happens in you never
have a fork so at most you suspend the
production of blocks which by the way is
okay because in a distributed system if
an adversary cuts all wires and to me to
you and we are in a Faraday cage can we
produce blocks no but what we want is
that if we suspend the blocks for a
while we want to when we restart
connectivity nobody loses money that's
what we want
and you're not go on the methods of a
case in Bitcoin is not okay
long story short to say we are receiving
to network partition and network attacks
what is the big advantage but somehow we
can use untrusted servers to act as a
relay to change my messages you make a
rule that you want to be a real a node
you can welcome you are really not - so
there is at least overlay nodes and
anybody is welcome and I don't have to
trust them right because the worst comes
to worse then the block is generation is
stopped but nobody loses money and
because of it I think that you are
better off at this point to tell
something to really know them than they
really know the expansive and it's much
more much a better way of much faster
way to communicate but it should only be
used if your block chain is partition
resilient if is if he's not partition
resilient he should never get there so
that's another an aspect of the security
that you can actually spend it in
efficiency you have mentioned about this
compactor database to keep the database
manageable for transactions going
forward
can this compactor database be a hash a
long hair no it has to be something more
complicated than bet because once you
will if you hush something together in
order to continue or to Enosh all kinds
of things yeah he has to be orchestrated
a little bit more yeah some ashing is
involved money cannot be justa you know
what I'm tempted to quit while I'm ahead
recursive Aria motive
you
[Applause]